transporteur général de la commission
des affaires sociales Madame Elisabeth
Doisneau
madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le vice-président de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse mes chers collègues monsieur
le Président Kanner vous venez de
présenter au nom de votre groupe et
celui de la présidence Eliana Cessy et
du président Guillaume Gontard cette
motion référendaire
nous nous y attendions ce n'est pas une
surprise vous dire si c'est une
un outil on va pas appeler ça une arme
de destruction majeure sans doute pas
sans doute pas chacun
use des outils qu'il a dans sa boîte à
outils
je voudrais je voudrais vous faire part
de deux de deux éléments d'abord une
incompréhension et d'autre part une
conviction pourquoi une incompréhension
parce que monsieur le Président kaner je
sais combien vous êtes attachés à la
démocratie parlementaire vous avez
tellement d'occasions de le montrer vous
avez tellement d'occasions de le prouver
et là aujourd'hui vous nous proposez
finalement un court-circuit on ne
débattrait pas au Parlement on
laisserait la rue choisir pour pour les
Français
alors je vois que ça vous fait réagir
c'est bien c'est bien ça fait réagir ça
fait réagir mais moi je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur Kanner les paroles de
François Hollande qui était de gauche il
me semble et qui disait il faut
respecter la démocratie représentative
pourquoi élire des députés pourquoi
élire des sénateurs si toutes les
questions peuvent être posées au peuple
français et cette François Hollande
[Applaudissements]
alors revenons à notre sujet si on
posait la question français voulez-vous
de cette loi vous savez bien que c'est
une question binaire oui ou non répondre
à une telle question évidemment demander
des efforts aux Français ils vont
répondre non et d'ailleurs les sondages
le montrent mais si on leur dit
voulez-vous sauver votre système de
réforme par répartition il vous diront
oui est-ce que vous voulez laisser la
dette de vos comment retraite et celles
et vos propres
pensions
est-ce que vous voulez leur laisser ils
diront non
donc je pense qu'il faut être attentif
il faut être attentif aux questions que
l'on pose lors d'un référendum et en
tout cas je ne pense pas qu'ici ce soit
une solution à adopter ma conviction
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui un mur
de dette et ça c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est encore un socialiste c'est bien
Moscovici le président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques nous dit que nous
avons un mur de dette et que nous avons
une montagne d'investissement une
montagne d'investissement pour les
armées pour le climat pour restaurer le
service public bref nous avons des
investissements à faire 155 milliards de
dettes encore à amortir sur la Cadès
vous imaginez un petit peu la somme que
ça fait et donc moi je veux pas laisser
cette décision cette décision qui est
lourde j'en prends la responsabilité je
ne veux pas donner voilà au peuple
français c'est responsabilité parce que
j'estime que nous avons à la prendre ici
au Parlement
je voudrais je voudrais aussi terminer
et je veux pas parapher par phrasé le
président Chirac qui disait la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs mais là
en tout cas nous oublions la dette et
nous regardons ailleurs je vous propose
de rejeter cette notion de référendaire
merci Madame la rapporteur général
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je donne la parole au
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse
de la Commission des affaires